[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIDYA ADALA: Thank you very
much for being with us here
at Cloud Next and specifically
for this IoT session with Zebra
and MicroEJ, our partners.
I know it's after lunch and
it's very crowded outside,
so let me start with
something real quick.
How many of you went to
the registration desk
to get one of these badges
yesterday or this morning?
Good, it's good to see
everybody raising hands.
I would be worried about
our security otherwise.
So when I went, I
was really excited
because behind the
registration desk
I saw this whole bank
of Zebra printers
that were printing these badges
real time when we came in.
And I was really excited
because that is actually
the exact thing we are
here to talk about.
So we'll show you a live
demo with that printer
and we have Zebra, who is a
leader in the printer market
globally, and we
have MicroEJ, who
is a Google Cloud
technology partner who
enables these types
of devices to get
smart and connected online
really quickly and securely.
So with that as the context--
so we have the
three speakers here.
I'm Vidya Adala, I'm
part of Google Cloud,
and my focus and
responsibility is
on developing the Edge ecosystem
around Google Cloud IoT.
With that, I just wanted
to talk a little bit
about the role Google plays
in bringing this whole use
case to reality.
So if you think about
IoT, the biggest technical
challenges around the
heterogeneous devices--
what I mean by
heterogeneous is devices
come in all sorts of
shapes and colors.
Compute capability
various, memory capability,
varies, cost, form
factor, the environments
that these devices operate
in, as well, vary a lot.
And in connecting all of
these seamlessly, reliably
to the cloud, this is a problem
that has not been solved.
And this is where a partner
like MicroEJ comes in.
They are a Google Cloud
technology partner
and their stack, basically,
sits on the devices at the Edge.
What it does is it makes the
data collection and ingestion
process very seamless,
very easy, and very secure.
As Google Cloud, we see
our role in making sure
that the infrastructure and
the plumbing for getting
this data to the cloud is
done in a secure, reliable,
and scalable manner.
But MicroEJ has a
virtualized environment
that sits on the edge and makes
working with the operating
systems that operate on
these devices much easier.
So if you think about it,
MicroEJ plus Google Cloud
is what creates the end-to-end
platform that can be deployed
on a whole range of devices.
We will talk about the handheld
mobile printer use case here,
but it can be deployed on
a whole range of devices
in a very, very reliable
manner, which is a big pain
point in IoT today.
The last thing I
want to call out
before I have the next feature
speaker come on stage--
Victor Salmons-- is the fact
that both MicroEJ and Google
Cloud share a fundamental
philosophy about the usage
of the platform.
We want it to be no
code, at most low code,
but low code also
in a modular way,
so that when developers,
like yourselves, are
using this platform, you
don't have to rewrite anything
from scratch.
That defeats the purpose
of our existence.
And the second
thing is security,
which is very much a no
compromise in the IoT space.
The single fastest way to
have an IoT project shelved
is to have the risk of
negative PR or devices hacked.
So with this technology
and approach,
we worked with Zebra together.
Also we're honored to have them
as a partner for Google Cloud
to connect these printers,
to make them online,
and real time interactable.
With that, let me call on stage
Victor Salmons, who heads up
new product development at
Zebra in your specialty printer
business, who will talk us
through the whys of this use
case and then Fred
Rivard will talk us
through the how and the
technological detail that
has gone into this.
We are very happy
to have you share
your story with us, Victor.
Thank you.
VICTOR SALMONS: All right.
Good afternoon, folks.
It's really a pleasure to
be here and talk with you
about Zebra Technologies.
We're going to talk
about thermal printers
and we're going to talk about
our partnership with MicroEJ.
So let's start with printers.
Printers, they're
mission critical devices
that live in our
customers' environments.
We need to deliver
labels, receipts, cards
when the customers want it.
I mean, these are real
time embedded devices.
They're electromechanical,
really complex devices.
And they are constrained.
We know constrained devices
in the embedded world.
They're constrained
by their design,
they're constrained
by the cost--
we're always trading those
off-- constrained by lifecycle.
We're also constrained by
that real time component.
And what comes to mind is
a use case that we have.
We print at 12 inches per
second and 400 microseconds
is really, really
critical in that use case.
So think about-- we have to get
data through the system, format
bitmaps, make bitmaps,
get them into a printhead,
and at 12 inches per
second we're pumping 2,400
dots an eighth of a millimeter.
2,400 dots an eighth
of a millimeter
every 400 microseconds, that's
that real time constraint
that we have to
live under in order
to deliver on those mission
critical applications
for our customers.
But in this day and age,
we need to go faster.
All that real time stuff takes
us time to develop to make sure
we get it right--
make sure we get it
right every single time.
So imagine in this
day and age where
things are moving so quickly--
IoT is moving, use
cases are changing--
imagine if we could have a
way to go faster, and develop
applications on top of that real
time, and keep them separated--
keep them managed, so that
we're delivering that real time,
but we're able to go faster
and make those applications.
I think we have solved that
with our MicroEJ partnership.
So I'm going to tease you
with that a little bit
and talk about it in
a minute, but first I
want to talk about
Zebra Technologies.
You see Zebra Technologies every
day in your day-to-day life.
We're right there
in front of you.
You see us in retail helping
you to purchase that shirt
or your favorite dress.
You see us with that delivery
driver getting that package
to your doorstep
quickly and reliably.
You see us in health
care, matching patients
with critical medications.
When your car is returned
through that rental car,
we're there to get
you fast through it
and get you to your terminal.
And, last but not least,
you see us in the NFL.
That's right, we're tracking and
tracing players in real time.
That's Zebra.
We're right there
in front of you
and I'll just give you
a little bit of history.
Zebra's celebrating 50 years as
a technology company this year.
We've been at it for 50 years.
I heard recently that most
companies-- the average company
lasts about 15 years, so
we're real excited about that.
We're a $4.2 billion company.
We have over 7,000 employees
throughout the globe,
sell in 180 countries, about 95%
of the Fortune 500 companies.
But we grew up with printers.
I've been a printer
guy for a long time.
We grew up with printers
but we are much, much more.
Zebra is an end-to-end
solution company.
Take a look at
all the components
that we bring together in
order to solve our customer
unique needs--
workflow optimizations,
productivity improvements.
All of it come from
this suite of products
that build on that solution
from barcode printing,
mobile computers, scanners,
locationing devices, as I
mentioned with the NFL.
Data platforms.
We have introduced a data
platform that aggregates all
that data-- it's powered by
Google-- called Savannah--
aggregates all of
that IoT data so
that we can create solutions--
software and solutions.
And our partners can also
create those solutions.
Services and supplies
round out all of those ways
that we're solving
problems for our customers.
And the way that
we think about it
is we sense what's going
on out on that edge,
analyze it, and act on it.
That is Zebra Technologies.
We're not that printer
company that we grew up to be,
we're definitely that
end-to-end solution company.
All right.
Let's go back to printers.
I've been staring at
this slide for a while.
And I am so proud
when I look at this.
I think printers
are a work of art.
These mission critical thermal
transfer-- thermal printers
are really a work of art.
And when you look at
this picture here,
we've built out this
powerful OS that
takes care of that real time
component, like I mentioned,
and on top of it, we've built
all of these applications.
And at the end of the
day you look at it--
we're solving-- we're building
this horizontal solution
set, this ecosystem, in order
to solve problems and help
our customers in four key
verticals-- in retail,
health care, T&O,
and in manufacturing.
You look at this and say we
are solving problems every day,
but--
and I don't say
but, but-- and there
are still unique needs out
there that our customers demand.
There are new use cases.
There are new application needs.
So what have we done?
We created a custom
application group--
all of this internally--
to build and solve
those customer issues.
But we-- and we solve
those problems every day--
from standalone
application, emulations,
integrations-- all of them with
that custom application group.
They solve hundreds of customer
unique cases every year.
But think if where there was
a way that we could open up
this powerful engine that we
have here, that we've built,
and make it
available to others--
make it available to
outside developers
in order to go faster and allow
them to solve those problems.
So that's where this unique
solution comes in with MicroEJ.
So take a look at what this
looks like and imagine building
a secure--
and that's the most
important part--
a secure Java-based application
engine that sits on top of all
of that real time stuff
that Zebra will take care
of, so that you can go faster--
taking advantage of all of
those standard libraries that
exist in Java--
allows you to go faster,
solve unique problems more
efficiently, and keep
that real time stuff
and keep that application
stuff separated.
If you step back and
look at it, it really
looks like that app
revolution that you
saw in the mobile world coming
into the embedded printing
world.
It's a very powerful
picture where
we're enabling external
developers really
three benefits.
We enable external
developers to develop
these new and unique use cases
and we see them every day,
maybe web browsing, template
printing that is required
that you can develop yourself.
Second, it probably and it will
help our internal development.
I mentioned all that work
that goes on internally,
now we can start to take
advantage of the same Java
capabilities, and build
out those capabilities,
and some of them end up
in that channel release
that I showed you on
the previous slide.
And third-- there is a third
subtle one that you see here.
You've got this powerful engine
that's sitting on the edge--
performing on the edge, let's
give it more responsibility,
take on some of the
hardware that's out there,
and get rid of that hardware,
and let the printer do it
itself--
write those
applications yourself.
So where are we at with this?
So recently-- a few months ago
at the Consumer Electronics
Show--
we showed two demos that show
you the possibilities here.
First, we implemented and
connected to the Google IoT
platform, implemented MQTT
very quickly through that Java
engine, took advantage
of the Twitter client,
and were able to send messages
back and forth very quickly
to a card printer and
a thermal printer.
And, third, we were able to take
advantage of the Google Maps
client, which we'll
see a demo on,
to be able to show location
information directly on a card
and on the UI--
all of this coming from that
Java-based application engine.
So you can think of
the possibilities
of keeping that
application layer separated
from that real time layer--
let us sweat that and make
sure that we get that right
and enables others
to develop solutions.
We're real excited about our
partnership with MicroEJ.
And what I'd like
to do now is say
thank you very much
for the opportunity
to present Zebra thermal
printers and MicroEJ.
And I'll introduce Fred Rivard,
who is the CEO of MicroEJ.
He'll take you through
the demos as well as
dig into some of the details
on these great solutions.
FRED RIVARD: Thank you.
Thank you-- thank you, Victor.
So I'm going to go
directly to a demo.
And so as I'm booting
the real device,
I will do a future device demo.
So I'm going to
switch to my PC--
if Justin can do
that, OK, thanks--
so Victor mentioned that we
have loaded some kind of agents.
So when we started for the
demo for CES and for today,
the idea was to pick
up what's already
in the Zebra store in
terms of application--
just like on your
Android phone--
you have application
you can download.
So we downloaded the agents
that connect to Google Cloud.
Of course, with the
MQTT we connected--
we downloaded also
the Twitter, the map--
Google Map agent,
et cetera, so all
that has been combined
very easily on the printer.
And here you can see
a virtual device.
So as soon as you have
some virtualization layer
so you can work using what
you have on your PC desktop,
so you don't need all the 40
different product line in terms
of printer on your desk to be
able to write an application.
So let's go through
a few of them.
So, obviously, the very standard
one is to create a watch,
so it's very standard,
so you can, of course,
download any kind of
watch on your printer.
It gives us the time.
And let's go on the-- let's
say, the Twitter agent.
So I think that Robert is going
to tweet some live tweets.
You just did it.
So let's go and
see if we can see
the very last tweet of Robert.
Yes, here, so we can see the
several, let's say, tweets--
live print.
And so all that,
in fact, reflects
some code that is running on
the virtual device and let's
now print on the virtual device.
So, obviously,
the virtual device
do not have any printing
agent, so it will just
show you what's
going to be printed
if it was a real printer.
And we can now take
a look at what's
on the connected
analytics on Google Cloud,
so when the printer
has printed the card,
it also sent to the
cloud that some data is
like the temperature of the
printerhead and, of course,
the last print--
the tweet-- it's a tweet
that has been done by Robert.
So that's real life and so all
that, in fact, allowed people
to design applications very
fast on the virtual device.
And I'm going to
switch with a very--
the real device now, so that
you can see it's the same.
And because a very
simple, let's say,
binary piece of code software
is running on the virtual device
and on the real device,
there's no issue.
You will have the very
same kind of behavior.
I'm going to switch
to my camera.
Yeah, so the watch--
same watch on both printers and
let's go to the Twitter app.
So here you-- because
the screen is very small,
the way to select an application
is to scroll the application
one by one.
So let's go to the Twitter.
So it's currently connecting
to the Twitter server
and it's going to
load all the tweets.
And this one is from [INAUDIBLE]
for-- some reason it's not
connected to the
one-- but anyway--
so I can then ask
to print that tweet.
And so currently you can hear
for those that are connected--
on that front row, you can
probably understand and feel
the sound of the printer.
So a card is going
to be printed out
and it will exactly
reflect what has been
printed on the virtual device.
So how long does it take for
one guy to do the CS demo?
Roughly, one
engineer, three weeks.
I don't know if you can see it.
All right-- and the tweet--
yeah, so, basically,
we have managed
to have this printing engine
loaded with an image that
has been computed onboard
live from, let's say,
data that has been
sent over by the the--
grabbed from the internet,
and the Google Cloud, Twitter.
So that's the demo
we just went through.
So, basically, some apps
that has been loaded
and one very important
one is a ZPL engine,
which is how you connect
to the underneath engine
of the printer.
Victor was mentioning it.
So we have this Google
Cloud agent, the second one
on the right, and
which, in fact,
allow you to publish and
subscribe to any MQTT channel.
So it means as soon you
wrote that on your device,
then you are connected
to Google Cloud.
And it's done for any
hardware, any of those--
let's say, [INAUDIBLE]
OS underneath.
The behavior of that piece
of code, that software,
remains the same.
So you don't have to retest,
recompile, rebuild, et cetera.
This is one-- you write
this software agent once
and it can run and be deployed
on any device, any printer.
So how does it work?
So I've been asked
to give you a bit
of a sense of the technology.
So, obviously, if
you look at what
has been done on the Android,
for example, when Android came
up, we were able to
phone and, let's say,
as soon Android came up five
years later, 80% of the phone
were running Android and
that marketplace for the apps
were roughly one million apps.
So it mean that if you are able
to let people write application
on any hardware--
because all these
smartphone are very diverse,
various hardware, et cetera--
it means that you can
create a lot of value
out of this concept
of virtualization.
So this is exactly what
we've done at MicroEJ.
We've been able to create
a small, tiny [? sibling ?]
of virtualization that
is used by Android
and we target all device
that are cost effective.
Because, in fact, we
had to reduce the size
of the core engine of MicroEJ--
of Android by 1,000
times smaller.
So, basically, we
target every processors
that are below $12 to $15.
And the size of
the engine itself
is roughly 30k which is
very, very, very small.
We can even say tiny.
So let's go a bit--
let's go through what we do.
Most people tend to compare
[? earth ?] to Android,
so that's how we
position ourselves.
And in terms of, I would
say, what makes that happen--
so one key message is
that virtualization
is something that, in
fact, allow you to decouple
the hardware from the software.
And so this is,
basically, what has
been done-- reducing
the size of the needed,
let's say, layer to
virtualize a software.
So, yeah, we have some kind of
companion, Android on one side
and MicroEJ on the other side,
to target all these devices.
And something which is
very important for IoT--
creating a device, connecting
the device to the cloud--
that's quite easy, in
fact, and [INAUDIBLE]
something well-known,
well-addressed by lots of,
let's say, industry.
But as soon you have
a fleet of device--
lots of different,
various devices--
they are not at all the
same in terms of hardware,
in terms of software
running on it.
The OS is different,
the version of the OS,
all that change along
the time and there
is a need to be
able to, let's say,
capture and create software
assets on top of that.
So this is a virtualization
that, in fact, we've
been able to downsize from
30 mega to, let's say,
30k in terms of size
of the footprint--
of the virtualization layer.
So if you think
as someone that is
in need to design
a new device, you
will have to find
the right processor.
You have right there,
roughly, 1,000--
or 10,000 different processors.
Compilers, you have, roughly,
four to five compilers.
OSes, same, less
than 10, et cetera.
If you multiply all that,
the combination of all that
is what we call the metrics
of pain for the software.
And it's-- this huge diversity
is almost impossible to handle
in a very cost effective way.
So let's think about
Android when they came up.
Just after four or
five years, they
took all the market
of the smartphone
just because, in fact, when
you have an application,
you can download
it on any device.
And the next device
we'll be able to load
the old application, et cetera.
So it means that you take out
whole lifecycle of the software
asset from the hardware.
So we are pretty much similar.
We provide virtual
device, multi-sandbox,
application store,
the two main languages
are C and Java for that program.
Of course, we support
other languages,
but that's the
main two languages.
In terms of markets, we
target probably the same kind
of market, but only on the
cost effective devices--
so wearables, medical devices,
energy meters, medical device,
lightning [INAUDIBLE],,
obviously, building automation,
smart home, et cetera.
We roughly have 30 million
devices followed by MicroEJ
that has been sold so far now.
And we partnered with Google
to provide a very seamless way
to connect and to have,
let's say, the plumbing--
the plumbing between the devices
and the cloud is something
that's--
shall not be, let's say,
handled by the developers,
especially if the-- just
think about an evolution
of the plumbing.
Of course, there will
be a V2, V3, V4--
and what about all
the application
running on both sides?
So the plumbing needs to be able
to evolve without impacting,
in fact, the applications-- the
assets that have been created
by your ecosystems.
So that's what we do
with Google as partner.
We provide the
edge computing side
in terms of the
virtualization and Google
provides the cloud part.
So Victor mentioned something
very, very important--
security--
security for a lot
of various devices.
So how do we do and do we
ensure that there is no way
for an application to go
into the printer engine
and that's-- you can, in
fact, open your platform--
the printers to an ecosystem of
independent software vendors,
so for them to create
new apps, et cetera.
So it needs to be
very bulletproof
and there is no
[? compromise ?] on security.
So we do that with sandboxes.
So we use sandbox, so each
means that every application is,
in fact, into its own
container and it cannot escape.
And the one way to
do that is to reuse
what has been used for
smartcard, in fact.
So we tend to use the very
kind of technology that
are, in fact, for smartcard.
So you can load an
application into a smartcard,
same for here, but the
application can't get out.
And so the container,
the sandbox,
controls the execution of
the application, the grant--
if he wants-- if it
wants to communicate
underneath with a Zebra
co-printing activities.
So all that is completely
under control of the trusted
execution environment--
MicroEJ trusted
execution environment.
We call that V for virtual
And so if V is
execution environment
allow the printer to
connect to the Google Cloud,
then the application will be
able-- all the application will
be able to talk to
the Google agent
and then be able to publish
that asset to the cloud
to get analytics.
So all that is something
that is well-known from the,
let's say, technical
point of view,
but how do you ensure that the
sandbox itself is protected,
is well-designed,
and there is no flaw,
and you can tweak it so
that you can, in fact, get
into the underneath
labor, the core printing
that you want to protect.
So that's my technical
slide, in fact.
So we have what we call
binary code inspection.
So we are able to verify before
the application is loaded,
or complied on, or
linked to your device,
that it does not have
any malicious code.
So we can do that by
doing a huge analysis
of the binary code,
your software,
and if it doesn't fit the
semantics of the sandbox,
of the virtual
execution environment,
then it is not allowed to run.
And doing-- thanks
to that, there
is no way to overcome the
trusted execution environment.
And that has been proved in
the let's say, 20 years ago
for the smartcard.
So there is no way to--
from the, let's
say, the application
itself to attack the
underneath system.
So think about the system
where the mass majority
of application are, in fact,
controlled by this trusted
execution environment.
It means that this--
the attackers, the
people that wants to,
in fact, take into
the controls of device
to do bad things with it--
the size of the
code that you need
to be sure that there is no
burden, no flow, et cetera,
is reduced to the
minimum [INAUDIBLE]..
And so that's helps a lot
in terms of having a cost
effective device.
It means that you protect
yourself from the attackers,
you open the device to a large
majority of a large community
and still you protect
your core engine.
That's the purpose.
So virtualization
around MicroEJ has been
going through certification--
[INAUDIBLE] certification.
For those of you
that know what it is,
that means there
is a probability
of bug very, very, very low--
almost none.
So combined with
the binary checking,
it's a very robust solution.
So this is almost my last slide.
So what we've been able
to create with our partner
Google for Zebra.
So there's Zebra engineers--
they create printers,
they know very well
their job, how to print.
That's something very hard,
as Victor's explained,
it's a real time engine, timing
needs to be very accurate.
And so in order to-- so that's
their core capabilities that
needs to be protected, so
it provide this print--
these printers with
a printing engine.
On top of that, you want
to have a community that
creates applications
like a Twitter,
being able to load a
map, being able to create
a fancy card by adjusting
maps, addresses, [INAUDIBLE],,
et cetera, on their printer.
All that is quite easy to do.
A regular engineer can
do that in a few days.
So in order to give them
the possibility to do that,
you create a virtual device.
And then you can create
your app on your PC
without even having a
printer on your desk.
Obviously, having all
the printers on your desk
is quite a challenge.
So that's the right--
the left-- the right part.
So you have what we call
an [INAUDIBLE] [? repair ?]
studio, so that you can create
apps and then, of course,
benefit from the
ecosystem with a store
where you can load and store
all the software assets.
Then, underneath, you have this
trusted execution [INAUDIBLE]
where you load all these apps--
that you can download
them dynamically,
meaning that you have a
new protocol coming in,
you have your device
a printer in the field
since, let's say, five years,
and you have a new protocol,
then you can then load this
new protocol into its sandbox
and still it's going to be safe.
You don't need to reassess
all the other printer.
And, of course,
there's these agents
on the right that allow you
to communicate with the Google
Cloud Platform and
you can download
that application that
agent on all your printers.
It's going to be the very same.
And imagine that Google
is changing its way
to communicate with the
Google Cloud Platform,
you just have to load the V2
of that guy and this is it.
It's going to be available
for all your printer.
So there is no more protocol
issues, you are future-proof.
You're cost effective
because you write once.
Your application, you
can deploy it everywhere
in a very secure way and without
compromising the core printing
knowledge of Zebra.
[MUSIC PLAYING]